i think it's fair to say
however good we get at keeping humans
and sharks apart in the ocean
there will always be moments when we
meet
and in those worst case scenarios when
sharks bite
is there anything that can be done
charlie houveneers is a scientist who's
thought more about this than most
hey mate how are you
for several years he's been looking at
ways of deterring sharks
that decide to attack is your uh
research and line of work due to your
passion and love for sharks or passion
and love for humans or
who are you who are you more invested in
it's okay to say the sharks too you do
things in my situations but yeah it's
it's a combination it's really i've
always been interested in shock since
i'm a kid
yeah and yeah the fascination for sharks
just changing to a
real interest in in the science and
understanding the sharks better so that
we can actually help
and providing a safer environment for
for people but also for sharks yeah
are you going into the field soon to
test any of those deterrents
yeah actually we're going next week well
good luck with it thanks
charlie and his colleagues from flinders
university in adelaide
are heading into the seas off south
australia
on board they're testing the latest
shark deterrent and protection
technologies
so what we've seen is that in the recent
years there has been an increase in the
number
of sharper globally including in
australia and this has resulted
in a lot of interest in the devices to
try to reduce those risks
the team have sailed to the neptune
islands a hot spot for great whites
the sharks come here to prey on
australia's largest colony
of long-nosed fur seals
so it's the perfect place to test
products designed to take advantage of
shark's very unusual senses
there's only a small number of animals
that have this ability to
detect electric field and sharks have it
through these black
dots called ampulla of lorenzini the
idea behind these electric field-based
deterrents
is that they will produce such a strong
pulse
that it will overwhelm the sensory organ
and make the shark basically move away
from the source
the aim is to develop a safer surfboard
with an electrical shark deterrent built
into it
this produces an electric field through
two electrodes which are positioned just
underneath the board and this is kind of
a replica
of a surfboard this is produced a field
which is transmitted to this electrode
and creates a bit of a barrier around
the surfboard
which in theory should be deterring the
sharks
to test the theory the experiment
compares a shark's reactions
to a board with the electrical device
switched on
to a board with it off
but getting robust data means repeating
the process
many times over
over hundreds of previous trials the
team have captured remarkable footage of
sharks in action
first they recorded what happened to a
baited board with a device turned off
it's interesting that we do have a bait
just underneath that board
swimming as we would expect to see it
swimming around a bait
and then what happened to the sharks
when the device was turned on
[Music]
so that was a pretty obvious flinch he's
coming back now
that kind of flinching reaction we
didn't see that when the deterrent was
turned off
and you can see the really obvious
flinching in the gills as well in the
jaw
gaping
well look at that one so that one came
really from down below it was only
within half a meter
overall there was a 60 reduction in the
proportion of weight being taken so 60
reduction in shark bites
if the eight people killed by sharks in
australia in 2020
had been able to use an electric to turn
like this
then five may still be alive
[Music]
products like these are promising
as we may be able to reduce fatalities
in the future
all without harming the sharks
you